Hello and welcome to the game packaging and publishing course in Unreal Engine 5.6
Now, it should be noted that a lot of the things that we're going through today
can be covered in a lot of different Unreal Engine versions
This isn't just Unreal Engine version 5.6
Maybe some of the UIs might change, but overall the principles should remain
So it's kind of an Unreal Engine agnostic engine version today
And today we're looking at packaging
And packaging inside of Unreal Engine really couldn't be easier
Unreal Engine makes it very easy just out of the box to package your game
And deploy it into an executable
So to do this, we can just click platforms at the top of your editor screen
You can see the platforms icon at the top of this image here
And today we'll just be packaging for Windows
Because that's the most straightforward for the purposes of today's tutorial
But any other devices that you have linked to Unreal Engine will appear here
And you can go ahead and highlight windows
And click package project
And when you click package project, you'll be told to pick a destination
You could just call this your desktop or somewhere else
But once you have picked a location to package your project
You'll see an icon like this appear in the bottom right hand corner of your editor screen
And it'll just go ahead and say packaging project for Windows
And depending on your project, it could take 30 seconds
It could take 5 hours or anywhere in between
But suffice to say, it'll be working in the background to package your project
So now is probably a good time to go and get a little drink
Wait for your project to package
And then hopefully you'll get a little green tick
And that's it, we're done
So I mean you package your game
It'll be a deployable executable
And I mean that's the course complete
So a really nice short tutorial video
Now of course, things aren't always as simple as that
And although Unreal Engine does make it very user friendly
Just to package your game out of the box
We do want to learn a little bit more about packaging
And also publishing our game
So let's dig into that a little bit more
So today it'd be nice to cover these three key areas
And it just so happens they have some nice alliteration with P's going on
So we'll be covering the projects, the packaging and the publishing
Across today's class
And just exactly what goes into each of these sections
Of course I've provided some links to skip to each section
So if you're trying to just locate a specific area
Feel free to just click the link and skip to the section you're looking for
Now we want to start with our project settings
And project settings allow you to customize your project
So I'll show you in a second where you actually find the project settings
But just to start off with explaining a little bit about what they are
Here we can just customize our project essentially
So we can change maybe our project's thumbnail
Which we'll talk about at the end of this course
Maybe you want a little splash movie to play at the start of your game project
You may want to edit input configurations here
If you weren't using the enhanced input system
This is where you'd add basic inputs
Maybe you want to choose which map or level to load on startup
All these things can kind of be found in project settings
You can also edit project settings from the configs folder
So if you were looking at an Unreal Engine project folder on your desktop for example
You'd see a few different folders there
You might say content, config, binaries, things like this
It's where your little blue U project icon lives
So in that config folder are actually settings that you can edit directly in a notepad
But editing these can be more user friendly in engines
So it's just a way to get to the desired result of what you're looking for
But essentially the project settings can be found under your edit button
So if you click edit at the top of your editor window
Go down to project settings
This is where we'll find the whole host of project settings
Now project settings
You can see already from the scroll bar on the left hand side of the image there
There are a lot of project settings to find
And we won't go into every single one today
You'll get to know the few that you end up editing on a frequent basis
But suffice to say at the top in the project settings
There's a lot of good just customizable options
Just for packaging and publishing your project
Which you may want to look through in your own time
Now the handy thing about project settings is
There's a nice little search bar at the top of the project settings window
So you can just search any term or name of something you're looking for
And the search bar will hopefully bring up the thing that you want to edit
So if you're wanting to set up some AI navigation maybe
Or changing the global illumination settings
Or the way physics are handled in your project
All these can be found in the project settings
And you may just want to search a few terms
Just to see if what you're looking for lives in the project settings
Now by default as you saw at the very start of the tutorial here
And of course we'll go into more details about actually setting up the packaging behaviour of your game
But you'll have noticed that if you did just try running through the very quick exercise
Of just going through packaging, going making a cup of coffee and coming back
Hopefully your game will be packaged correctly
And if not I've got a few tools and tips of how to ensure that your game does package
But by default we saw that Unreal Engine packaged everything by default
So it does take the kitchen sink kind of mentality
Of just grab everything, try its best to package it and put it into an executable
Now this is intended behaviour
It makes it easy to get your games up and running without too much engine knowledge
But it's worth noting that it can increase package sizes and download sizes therefore
So you just really want to think a little bit about what you're actually packaging in your project
Especially if you've got a few different prototypes going on
And some sample behaviour that you don't really want in your main package project
But it's just there hanging around
You may just want to think about what you're actually trying to include in the package
Now I'll go into this tool on the right hand side in a few more slides
But this is called the size map
So you can actually right click on any asset inside of Unreal Engine in your content browser
And you can select size map
And again you can search in the right click bar as well
Just if you can't see the size map option
It might be hidden under asset actions
But you can see that multiple elements make up any kind of given actor inside of your content browser
So here we might have a static mesh for example
And the static mesh has a material assigned and a few textures
And you'll see that each one of them adds size to our package project
So you really want to be mindful about what you're packaging
To kind of create the most efficient download size for your end user
So it's just worth noting about this kind of kitchen sink approach of including everything when packaging